so this may sound weird but I promise
it'll start to make sense eventually so
I sort of observed the other day that
there are two different ways that people
watch movies the first group of people
they get home from work they're pretty
tired so they sit on the couch they have
a Netflix subscription so they throw a
movie on it doesn't really matter what
it is as long as it's sort of
stimulating they'll be on their phone
they'll be eating something and they're
just sort of to have the movie on it's
just there for them group number two
operates completely differently when
they watch a movie it's a lot more
intentional maybe they looked up some
reviews on IMDB or maybe they heard from
a friend that was supposed to be really
good so they make a night out of it they
invite some friends over or they just
watch it themselves with headphones in
but they're actively engaged the whole
time I call this active movie watching
now being the film nerd that I am I fall
into group number two I very rarely just
put on a movie for the sake of putting
on a movie I really like film and I'm
really engaged in it and I like the
formalistic quality of it now as
snobbish as this makes me sound the
point of this video isn't to flex on you
about how cultured I am but to explain a
point the difference between passive
engagement and active engagement and how
getting them wrong can actually really
damage your entire lifestyle your
relationships with others and your work
and everything basically your whole life
can be ruined if you don't get this
right being actively engaged with
something increases the quality of the
thing that you're engaged with whether
it's your work a conversation active
engagement is better almost every single
time but there's a problem
active engagement requires willpower and
willpower is a finite resource so it's
difficult if not impossible to be
actively engaged with every single thing
throughout the entire day all day every
single day you're gonna completely burn
out a great example of this is we all
know a guy like Tom Tom spends a lot of
time at work he's doing really well in
his career and he's actively engaged
with the problems at work work problems
that's what problems at work are called
he's trying hard he's climbing the
ladder but he also has his family and by
the time he gets home he's so burnt out
from work that he sits on the couch
passively watches some TV cracks open a
beer
you know maybe his wife wants to talk
about some problems that she's having in
her life and he doesn't really you know
he's not really listening at all or
trying to offer any sort of help maybe
his son comes up to him and says dad can
we play outside but we throw the frisbee
and he's you know not today son and
sometimes you do need a day like this
maybe you can't be super engaged with
your family every time you get home from
work but for a lot of people like Tom
this is every single day and compounded
over weeks months and years this can
really put a strain on the relationships
in your life so perhaps you can relate
to Tom in your own kind of way maybe
you're spending a lot of energy on
things that you don't really care about
things that you don't enjoy and things
you find ultimately unfulfilled
which leaves you with next to no energy
for the things that are actually
important in your life so what's the
solution
do you just quit your job and sit in
your house in a meditative state waiting
for your wife and kids to come home the
solution is to become better at mental
energy management or men so here are
just a couple ways to better manage your
mental energy number one is to take a
survey of your typical day what do you
do at work what are your tasks at work
what do you do when you get home and
then figure out how much attention each
of those things really means so
obviously there are things at work that
actually do require your full attention
especially if you have a job that has a
lot of creative problem-solving but most
jobs also have areas which don't require
that much energy like writing an email
or answering a phone call sweeping the
floors things that you can really sort
of mentally disengage from write all
that stuff down figure out what things
are important what things you can engage
with and what things you can disengage
with but that's sort of the precursor to
the actual tips that I have and I have
four of them so tip number one is to
take more restorative breaks one thing
that I've noticed is that when I'm
actively engaged with my most important
work say I am video editing a very
creative say it's like a wedding video
or a corporate video I pretty much have
to be all there when I'm doing that but
when I take a break I make a critical
mistake and a lot of the time I just
browse reddit or I watch YouTube or I do
something like that I go on social media
on my
and that continues to work away at my
brain it's not actually restorative I'm
still mentally engaged with whatever's
in front of me and it's taxing it's not
actually relaxing what I should be doing
is going for a walk
meditating taking a nap maybe making
myself a snack all of these things cause
you to unplug and it sort of heals your
brain in a way things like browsing
reddit keeps your mind busy and by the
end of the day you're gonna be so pooped
out all you're gonna want to do is be a
zombie in front of a TV and breathe air
so tip number two is to force yourself
to physically and mentally relax during
less important tasks now this one sounds
kind of weird but it actually works
really well so say you have something
like a you know menial email that you're
supposed to write for an unimportant
client or say you're sweeping the floors
or something or making a sandwich
whatever your job is it's the part of
the job that doesn't require a lot of
thought what you should do is relax your
body when you're doing it relax your
body and mind and sort of ease float be
free now this may sound like a little
bit of whoo-whoo crap but it's certainly
not listen to me believe me actually you
don't have to believe me if you don't
want but what you can't deny is that our
physiology and psychology are intimately
linked in ways we can't even fully
comprehend yet what affects the body
often affects the mind and vice-versa
when you relax in your seat when you are
just a little bit more lackadaisical in
your posture you can mentally relax as
well so if you're stressed out writing
an email and you're angry at the client
and you're really rigid that's gonna
mentally wear you out so fast you don't
even realize it instead when you're
doing less important stuff that doesn't
require too much of your attention just
take it easy
maybe place some spa music get someone
lower down in the company to give you a
little foot rub and just you know be a
douche it's not that hard of work so
don't treat it like hard work treat it
like a little mini vacation before your
actual restorative breaks now tip number
three is probably the most important one
and that is to be more intentional with
how actively engaged you are with the
work that requires your attention so for
me that's video editing so when I sit
down to edit
I should be focused like really really
focused and I shouldn't break that focus
be very very efficient with my time so
that it can be over with quicker and
that's the key here being really really
efficient in the time that you do have
and your most important work can get it
over with quicker so that you have more
time to just relax
saving mental energy for the things that
are important in your life delegate a
parcel of time that you dedicate fully
to unadulterated productivity screw
multitasking I'm talking about diving
into one thing with your full attention
and being maximally effective if you
learn to do that for like two or three
hours and you enter this deep work space
you can get more done than you ever knew
possible not only that but it's over
with quicker so the rest of your day can
be a breeze now tip number four and this
is kind of the obvious one but it's it's
barely a tip it's more like a reminder
and that is just to take care of your
health obviously if you're not getting
enough sleep every night then you're not
gonna have the mental energy or
willpower to focus on the important
things in your life and mental energy
management just won't work all right
that's it guys so really take mental
note or a physical note as to when
you're being more passively engaged and
when you're being more actively engaged
and figure out if it's congruent with
your actual values if you liked this
video make sure to hit like because when
you hit like the algorithm blesses me
with you know shoving this video in
other people's faces so it helps them
out it helps the video rank better and
if you're lurking here and this is a
couple times that you've seen my face
and you haven't hit subscribe yet
hitting subscribe really helps me out
and especially if you hit that Bell icon
so that you're notified when I release a
new video it's all helpful I want to do
this as a full-time job and once that's
actually feasible for me the quality of
these videos is going to increase so
much
I can't wait for what I'm able to create
for you guys I want to do like long-form
documentaries as well I'm almost there I
can almost do YouTube full-time
appreciate your guys's support
definitely write a comment down below to
let me know what you want to see in the
future or you know be one of those
thousands of people who comment the fact
that I somehow look like Mark Zuckerberg
I
still don't see it at all bros not even
bald I honestly prefer it if people
started calling me and Jason Statham but
I don't have the the jawline yet yet
that sounds like I'm working on my
jawline or if the tropics
yeah I'm Ewing